une question sur la continuité c'est
souvent une des difficultés de votre
partie dans la Nièvre alors on sait que
c'est vous venez de le dire c'est une
défaite qui est relativement lourde donc
c'est difficile de vraiment s'implanter
est-ce que vous vous souhaitez jouer le
pari de la continuité d'autres
candidatures importantes à des élections
nationales pour pouvoir améliorer vos
scores
alors tout d'abord la défaite est
indiscutable bien entendu mais Quentin
Nivernais sur deux ne se déplace pas
pour voter je pense qu'il ne faut pas en
tirer de de l'enseignement trop trop
hâtif ceci étant pour votre répondre à
votre question sur la continuité vous
savez je suis agriculteur et je sais
très bien que avant d'espérer récolter
il faut d'abord semer aujourd'hui j'ai
semé je j'ai semé aussi dans d'autres
sur d'autres territoires et les
nivernaises et les Nivernais peuvent
compter sur moi et sur ma volonté à
poursuivre cette action escamba oui
parce que c'est vrai que depuis Simone
rignaux finalement on la droite est en
lambeau dans la Nièvre qui ce qui manque
pour qu'elle se qu'elle se revivifie ou
qu'elle vive cette droite dans la Nièvre
on va très clairement il manque de
l'unité il manque de l'unité il manque
un leader et puis une ambition partagée
une ambition collective nous ne savons
pas nous rassembler sur sur des projets
et établir des stratégies précises voilà
les enjeux de demain établir des
stratégies et se mobiliser pour
atteindre les objectifs qu'on s'est
fixés